avec nous pour le match des idées ce
soir jean philippe derosier bienvenue
constitutionnaliste et professeur de
droit public à l'université de lille
pierre benoit pas beau du châtelard
bienvenue à vous également recteur
général du comité des juristes en marche
et vous êtes avocat au barreau de paris
merci à tous les deux d'être avec nous
ce soir
on entend beaucoup dire que c'est un
procès historique j'ai envie de dire la
difficulté ça va aussi être que ce
procès ne se transforme pas en règlement
de compte entre nicolas sarkozy les
juges dont on sait qu'ils ne s'aiment
pas beaucoup ça va être salé l'écueil à
éviter jean philippe derosier
oui pas seulement éviter les pressions
politiques et médiatiques de façon
générale et même populaire sur sur les
juges il faut il faut que la justice
fasse son travail
c'est à elle de dire si monsieur sarkozy
est coupable ou non s'il devait être
condamné ou non si la justice est en
droit de le poursuivre sur cette affaire
là parce qu'il ya une controverse aussi
à ce niveau là et donc c'est tout cela
qu'il faut effectivement laissé faire en
se gardant de manifester la moindre
pression sur les magistrats qui sont
effectivement vous l'avez vous l'avez
souligné les rapports entre
l'ancien président de la république et
la magistrature en général ne sont pas
forcément des plus sereins mais je pense
que les magistrats sont en mesure
d'accomplir leur devoir dans
l'indépendance requise
et puis il ya de toute façon plusieurs
degrés de juridiction qui permettent
justement sur le temps long si jamais il
devait y avoir un dysfonctionnement un
endroit de rétablir ce dysfonctionnement
le pnf a quand même comparé les méthodes
de l'ancien président à celle d'un
délinquant chevronné sa part sur des
bases un peu compliqué quand même dansé
dans ses relations entre nicolas sarkozy
et les magistrats
il a vraiment un caractère historique ce
procès pour vous en tant que juriste a
observé de l'extérieur c'est quand même
pas rien c'est une très bonne question
est ce que c'est un procès historique
avant ce procès on peut quand même
remarquer qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'hommes politiques qui ont fait l'objet
de procès on peut également noter que
jacques chirac lui même avait fait
l'objet d'un procès que jacques chirac a
été condamné
on savait que jacques chirac ne s'était
pas pour présenter présenter devant le
tribunal donc là c'est une différence
maintenant il convient également d'être
d'être assez mesuré est ce qu est ce qu
on doit se réjouir bon il convient
d'être d'être mesurés pourquoi parce que
comme tous les justiciables
nicolas sarkozy bénéficie de la
présomption d'innocence il a toujours
accompli tous les actes qui lui étaient
imposées par l'autorité judiciaire et
donc ce dont on peut se réjouir et ce
qui est historique encore une fois c'est
de voir que la chose la justice est
indépendante et qu'elle a pu mener 7
cette enquête et ce dossier de la façon
la plus sereine possible ce qui a
conduit nicolas sarkozy après son mandat
de recouvrer le statut d'un justiciable
comme un autre qui doit faire face à la
justice qui a les mêmes droits et les
mêmes devoirs vis-à-vis de l'autorité
judiciaire et l'indépendance de la
justice cij du rem c'est vraiment
quelque chose sur lequel on ne
tergiverse pas c'est vrai qu'un ancien
président devant les juges l'image
convient de revoir n est pas anodine
c'est quand même très particulier c'est
tout à l'honneur de la justice française
oui oui absolument mais comme l'a dit
mon débatteurs il faut enfin c'est un
justiciable comme les autres
effectivement dans une nature un petit
peu particulière parce que tous les
justiciables ne sont pas des anciens
présidents de la république
mais aux yeux de la justice aux yeux de
la justice
aux yeux de la loi c'est un justiciable
comme les autres qui sera défendue qui
se défendra comme les autres oui c'est
un procès historique parce que dans
toute l'histoire de la vème république
il n'y a eu que deux présidents de la
république ancien président impliqué
traduits devant les tribunaux
il n'y en a qu'un et c'est le premier
qui se présente devant les tribunaux
donc évidemment que ça a quelque chose
d'historique
maintenant il ne faut pas en faire un
procès pour l'histoire il faut pour pour
tout le monde pour monsieur sarkozy pour
ceux qui auront à le juger pour ceux qui
auront à le défendre et à défendre c'est
qu implique et ses coaccusés c'est que
les personnes qui sont poursuivies avec
lui notamment m e herzog et m et
monsieur azibert donc il faut parce que
c'est redevenu aux yeux de la loi un
justiciable comme les autres
il faut que ce soit un procès qui a les
yeux de l'alliance comme les autres il y
a le il faut on est bien d'accord mais à
ceux qui diraient que les juges
pourraient se payer nicolas sarkozy pour
le dire un peu vulgairement
qu'est-ce qu'on répond on répond que les
magistrats exercent leurs fonctions et
leurs devoirs en toute indépendance qui
lie à un certain nombre de garde-fous
pour veiller sur cela notamment le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
dans lequel les magistrats ne sont pas
majoritaires donc il y a garde fous
entre guillemets à l'extérieur oui oui
c'est important qu'il ya ce mécanisme
qui veille sur l'indépendance des
magistrats
100% de lehman de la magistrature n'est
pas hostile ou favorables à nicolas
sarkozy je pense que les magistrats sont
aussi en mesure de faire la part des
choses en particulier ceux qui sont
investis des fonctions de jugement les
magistrats du siège dans leur rôle de
dire la loi nous dire la justice de
rendre la justice
et puis il y a la procédure pénale qui
fait qu'il ya une première instance de
mende
la correctionnelle actuellement que si
jamais il devait y avoir une
condamnation ou même un non lieu
il peut y avoir un appel cour d'appel et
que en dernier lieu et puis avoir une
pourvoi en cassation donc il ya
différents degrés de juridiction qui
permet sur le temps long de la procédure
de rétablir un dysfonctionnement à un
moment donné et je peux je ne veux pas
croire je ne peux pas croire l'ensemble
des magistrats que nicolas sarkozy et
consorts rencontrerait tout au long de
la procédure de letia un seul objectif
en tête qui soit celui de se payer
monsieur sarkozy comme il ya quand même
de la politique chez les juges on le
sait on a eu les affaires comme le mur
des alors il ya la mécanique qui
est des garde-fous on le comprend bien
après il ya aussi la réalité et puis la
relation humaine n'ont aucun doute
pierre benoît pas vous du château là bas
je vous rejoins un petit peu ce que ce
que dit mon contradicteur le sujet ici
celui de la perception
finalement quelle est la perception que
va se faire l'opinion du travail des
juges
est-ce qu'il va y avoir des juges
pourraient être influencés dans un sens
comme dans l'autre
concernant le sort de nicolas sarkozy il
faut voir qu'objectivement aujourd'hui a
eu un certain nombre de recours qui ont
été déposés par nicolas sarkozy son
avocat par rapport aux procédures qui
sont en cours à chaque fois les voix de
droite qui ont voulu être sollicité par
l'ancien président de la république ont
à chaque fois été acceptée par
l'autorité judiciaire donc est vraiment
le le au delà de cette procédure pénale
il ya le caractère d'indépendance de
justice qu'il faut encore renforcer et
l'une des mesures que nous on défend et
sur laquelle on milite s'est renforcé
l'indépendance de la justice et
notamment obliger la nomination des
magistrats du parquet après avis
conforme du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature ce qui permettra c'est une
proposition du président l'an tout à
fait une proposition du candidat
emmanuel macron est donc bien évidemment
ce type de nouvelle mesure permettra de
renforcer l'indépendance de justice
de la même façon et là ça me permet de
faire un parallèle sur la question de
des fadettes et notamment
la décision qui avait été prise par eric
dupond-moretti de confier le dossier une
enquête administrative ouvre une enquête
du parquet a jugé partial financer après
avoir retiré lui-même sa plainte avant
d'être nommé garde des sceaux puis
d'avoir accepté de confier le dossier à
matignon est une décision qui a été
saluée la semaine dernière par la haute
autorité de transparence dans la vie
publique
donc là encore il est sous pression
aussi parc national financier finalement
dans ce procès à tiroirs notamment à
cause de cette affaire des fadettes
c'est une enquête qui a été menée un peu
discrètement et qui n'a pas plu à tout
le monde et notamment à l'actuelle garde
des sceaux c'est vrai que le parquet ait
financiers on sait pas une institution
qui existe depuis des décennies qui a
fourni un certain nombre de décisions
sur lesquelles on pourrait donner du
confort par rapport à son travail à ces
enquêtes au temps où pour marquer que
lorsqu'il intervient sur des affaires de
terrorisme
angèle ya un satisfecit et tout le monde
apprécie son travail mais c'est vrai que
lorsqu'il se mêlent à des affaires
politiques là tout de suite c'est bien
plus compliqué elle est deuxième point
juridique qui pose question ce soir
c'est le crime déco side qui ne sera pas
retenue dans le texte de loi que prépare
le gouvernement en réponse à la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
grandit
interview croisée hier dans le journal
du dimanche d'eric dupond-moretti et de
barbara pompili on en retient notamment
donc le crime déco site devient délit
d'atteinte à l'environnement et délits
général de pollution ce qui n'est
juridiquement pas du tout la même chose
on va demander à corinne lepage qu'elle
en pense bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre
dans ce match des idées vous êtes
présidente de cap21 le rassemblement
citoyen ancienne ministre de
l'environnement bien sûr est ce que vous
vous êtes déçu et ce que vous parliez
vous parleriez même de recul non non non
non c'est pas un recul il faut être très
clair c'est une avancée puisque enfin la
france va transcrire la directive
communautaire 2008 qui impose aux états
membres de d'utiliser le droit pénal
pour faire appliquer le droit de
l'environnement
il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui le droit
pénal de l'environnement est très pauvre
nous avons des infractions pour l'eau
nous n'en avons pas pour l'erm
nous n'avons pas pour les sols nous en
avons pour les espèces protégées pour
les installations classées
ce qui est puni c'est le non respect des
autorisations administratives
c'est pas autre chose donc le fait
d'introduire un délit généreux non c'est
un progrès là où par contre ça va pas
c'est de la plaie des lidd écocide parce
que ça n'a pas de sens pourquoi ça n'a
pas de sens c'est très simple à
comprendre écocide ça veut dire tu es
l'écosystème quand on tue ces mini psy
d' homicide même pesticides quand on tue
on n'est pas dans le domaine du délit on
est dans le domaine du crime et c'est la
raison pour laquelle on peut pas dire un
des leades écocide mais le crime déco
site pose des problèmes très particulier
et je peux comprendre que ces problèmes
puissent arrêter si je puis dire le
gouvernement pourquoi parce que le crime
déco side
il est très comment dire caractérisable
en matière internationale on parte
pourquoi parce que ce sont des
infractions qui vont concerner
massivement l'environnement par exemple
ce que fait monsieur bonnart ou en
détruisant la forêt amazonienne on
pourrait considérer que c'est un crime
d' écocide par exemple l'utilisation du
paraquat qu'on a eus voici pendant
quelques années et pendant des années
qui a complètement détruit la capacité
du sol à à produire et qui a eu des
conséquences en termes sanitaires
considérables
on pourrait se poser la question mais
vous des choses de très grande ampleur
souvent international et que donc c'est
difficile pour un état tout seul
d'introduire ce qui comprendraient au
niveau de la copine à l'international
par exemple
voilà donc moi je suis je le soutiens je
suis pour mais je vois bien les
difficultés juridiques mais là où je ne
suis pas d'accord c'est qu'on appelle
des l'idée qu'au site ce qui n'est que
le délit d'atteinte général à
l'environnement qui est un délit qui est
prévue au niveau du droit communautaire
gephac si j'étais simple et 6,6 alors en
tout cas pour ceux qui ont peut-être un
peu travaillé le dossier pour moi
c'était très clair ce soir vous
restez avec nous on va évidemment faire
un petit tour de réactions en plateau
parce que c'est vrai que vous l'avez
peut-être lui comme moi cette
justification à d'eric dupond moretti
dans le jdd il nous dit à l'
enthousiasme citoyens qui s'est exprimée
doit succéder une traduction juridique
dans le code pénal voilà la
justification du ministre de la justice
pour ne plus parler de crime
d'ecaussinnes mais deux d'élite
pollution ou de délit d' écocide est ce
que pour vous il y aurait eu un vrai
problème de constitutionnalité de crime
déco site si ça avait été inscrit comme
cela dans la loi jean philippe derosier
oui on ne sait pas de quoi on parle
donc oui si on dit le crime déco side
est passible de 10 ans de prison
oui on sait pas ce que c'est donc voilà
c'est inscrits et comme cela défie
l'ecosite je ne sais pas ce que c'est et
comme vient de le rappeler madame lepage
c'est presque un contresens dans le
lacis dans le signifier même nom les
délits descossy d'étain peut-être un
oxymore mais même les quelconques aussi
des échos si c'est à tuer c'est tuer
l'écosystème est donc je j'ai du mal à
identifier précisément ce que c'est
parce que l'ensemble de l'écosystème
tant qu'il ya de la vie et l'écosystème
survie donc je pense qu'effectivement il
faut préciser la terminologie juridique
dans et en particulier dans les
dispositions pénales qui sont commencés
d'interprétation stricte et donc qu'il
faut être le plus précis principe le
plus précis possible donc on ne peut pas
inscrire cela comme ça à tout va il faut
et qu'il y ait un débat on éteint
constituent incontestablement dans une
période où l'environnement est une
priorité et politiques mais surtout
mondial culturel de démocratique tout ce
que vous voulez parce que on voit bien
où tout cela nous mène si on continue
comme cela pour avoir un propos très
très générale et qu' il y a là une prise
de conscience politique mais aussi
précisément populaire ce qui ce qui est
montré par énormément d'initiatives ces
cinq dernières années de l'accord de
paris a à d'autres et dont la convention
citoyenne pour pour le climat il ne faut
pas que cette euphorie positive
populaire sur les matières
environnementale débouche sur une
euphorie juridique parce que précisément
ensuite on nage dans un flou qui va
nuire à la protection de l'environnement
et donc lorsque l'on se saisit de ces
débats au niveau parlementaire pour en
faire une traduction juridique ou faire
en faire même une traduction paix narnia
prince et la réalité qu'il faut être
rigoureux précis pour effectivement
aller dans le sens de la protection de
l'environnement et pas dans un sens où
on nage dans un flou absolu qui ne
permettent pas pour peut protéger cet
orient sauf que moi j'ai pas le souvenir
au moment où la convention citoyenne
pour le climat a évoqué cette demande de
crime déco site qu'on leur répondu
attention la traduction juridique ce ne
sera pas un crime d'ego side c'est
impossible c'est presque antico ces
mêmes anticonstitutionnelle il faudra
parler de délit et d'où la déception
d'ailleurs des citoyens de la convention
citoyenne et je vous donnerai la parole
dans un instant corinne lepage d'abord
pierre benoit pavot du châtelard c'est
ce qu'il faut souligner également c'est
qu'au moment où cette proposition était
faite par la convention citoyenne donc
149 proposition le président s'est
engagé à reprendre 146 lorsque cette
proposition était faite parmi les
experts juridiques de la convention
citoyenne qui avait travaillé sur la
question y avait déjà des doutes qui
s'est posé sur cette question de
possibilités de requalification en crime
pourquoi parce qu'il ya un crime en
droit français et doit être passibles de
dix ans de prison
il ya un principe de proportionalité à
respecter et les experts juridiques de
la convention citoyenne avait dit
attention c'est difficile à traduire
dans le code pénal comme étant un crime
est donc ce que s'est engagé à faire le
garde des sceaux avoir accompli c'est de
traduire le plus fidèlement possible
dans le code pénal les atteintes qu'ils
étaient
souligné alors la convention citoyenne
et dans ce cadre là
la proposition des deux délits alors moi
ce que j'ai lu j'ai obligé pas lui de
délits des quotidiens daily général de
pollution est un délit de mise en danger
de l'environnement paraît répondre à
cette question avec des sanctions qui
peuvent aller jusqu'à dix ans de prison
et ça rappelle quand même la priorité
gouvernementale en matière
d'environnement avec un plan de relance
qui conseille 30 milliards d'euros a
alors germé et juste pour finir pour
nous chez jure m le fait d'avoir un des
liens est en marche un juriste en bas
plutôt qu'un crime peut peut finalement
apporter des solutions pratiques et qui
satisferont la convention citoyenne du
climat par exemple un crime aujourd'hui
s'il doit faire l'objet d'une
appréciation judiciaire doit être
traduit devant la cour d'assises un jury
populaire et les jeunes populaires ne
seront peut-être pas aussi expert que
des juridictions spécialisées près des
tribunaux correctionnels qui pourront
juger de ce type de délit et et il est
notamment prévu par le garde des sceaux
d'avoir des juridictions spécialisées en
la matière parce qu'ils sont déçus
corinne lepage quand même les citoyens
on les entend et pas que les citoyens de
la convention citoyenne on a entendu des
sénateurs socialistes ici qu'ils étaient
déçus également
oui parce que si vous voulez ce que
propose le gouvernement est encore une
fois qui est un progrès ce n'est qu'une
obligation à laquelle nous étions forcés
et que nous n'avions pas voulu respecter
l'écocide est quelque chose de différent
en ce que c'est la prise de conscience
de la capacité à tuer le vivant est
derrière a tué l'homme parce que
derrière l'écocide vous avez ce que
j'appelle l'humanisme non pas le crime
contre l'humanité au sens de nuremberg
mais lui mais ni side en ce sens que
c'est l'espèce humaine qui peut
disparaître en tout ou en partie sans
référence à une culture une religion une
population et c est donc la gravité de
la situation actuelle sur le plan
environnemental nous confronte à cette
problématique là donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est très différent que
de mettre un terme à des gens qui vont
être sans foi ni loi et qui vont polluer
voilà
donc c'est un vrai sujet je ne pense pas
que ce soit un constitutionnel je pense
en revanche comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure qu'il y a une vraie difficulté
de définition du périmètre
ça veut dire quoi exactement ça change
et par vérifier mais dans le code pénal
on a déjà une disposition sur le crime
environnemental qui à ma connaissance
n'a jamais été utilisée ça existe
existent et mais en contrepartie ce
qu'il faut voir aussi c'est
qu'aujourd'hui endroits on a droit pénal
qui est très faible très faible
et lorsque on a des succès en matière
environnementale pénal c'est souvent sur
le droit commun et pas sur le droit de
l'environnement
je vous donne un exemple précis l'année
dernière nous avons faits jugés par la
cour d'appel de paris
la notion de mise en danger délibérée
d'autrui pour le dysfonctionnement d'un
incinérateur à côté de paris qui avait
créé un panache de dioxyde pendant des
années des années avec une augmentation
du risque de cancer de 80% de 32 20 %
par dont 20%
donc ce qu'a dit la cour s'est mise en
danger délibérée d'autrui
le vecteur c'est l'environnement huit
ans c'est l'humain dans l'écho site je
dirais que l'environnement n'est plus
seulement un vecteur c'est une victime
en tant que tel et donc on change de
paradigme on change d'échelle c'est
quelque chose de différent et ce sont
toutes les nuances sur ce sujet merci
infiniment corinne lepage d'avoir
participé à ce match des idées on va
passer à la troisième actualité
actualité forte qui touche à notre droit
c'est cette loi sécurité globale qui
fait couler beaucoup d'encre je rappelle
rapidement le problème
l'article 24 interdit de montrer le
visage des policiers s'y lie à volonté
porté atteinte à son intégrité
cela a suscité un tollé dans les
rédactions le journaliste mais pas
seulement
face à la polémique le gouvernement
était obligé de reculer cette fois et de
revoir cet article gérald darmanin a
déposé un amendement qui garantit la
liberté d'informer alors avant de vous
demander ce que vous en pensez messieurs
je voudrais la vie de lauriane show
l'aise qu'on accueille dans ce match des
idées également bienvenus
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
journaliste pour reporter et membre de
reporters en colère est ce que vous êtes
un petit peu rassuré après cet
amendement bonjour bonjour à toutes et à
tous je suis pas vraiment rassuré parce
qu'en fait cette loi sécurité globale
elle s'insère dans une certaine
continuité du gouvernement qui porte à
tous c'est ça la liberté de la presse
il ya eu le mot celle pas d'une peinture
qui a été publié en septembre dernier où
il y avait déjà des atteintes qui était
très problématique à la liberté
d'informer en manifestation avec la
question de s'accréditer en fait pour
les manifestations
l'obligation pour le journaliste de
devoir quitter les lieux aux premières
sommations
donc je suis pas vraiment rassuré par
alors la liaison est un petit peu
mauvaise j'espère que ça va fonctionner
sinon je vous proposerai peut-être de
passer par téléphone directement gérald
darmanin lui assure de son côté que ce
gouvernement est un ardent défenseur de
la liberté de la presse
du coup vous en doutez en fait j'ai le
sentiment que ça va vraiment pas dans le
bon sens monsieur dupont mon rythme en
réplique qui a envie de changer la la la
loi de 1881
je pense vraiment qu'aujourd'hui il ya
une volonté manifeste de limites et de
limiter la liberté de la preuve de
dignité la liberté d'informer au type de
citoyen parce que il faut dire dansé
dansé vidéo et c'est un outil de
protection en fait les gens utilisent
pas comme comme un outil de protection
face aux violences policières donc à la
fois dans les manifestations mais aussi
dans les quartiers populaires en fait
les gens pour faire cesser la paix
moyens et faibles moyens qu'ils ont pour
se protéger quand y'a décantait des
incidents avec la police
et qu'est ce que vous faites de la
protection des policiers eux-mêmes qui
peut être eux aussi sont comme le dit
gouvernement livré en pâture sur les
réseaux sociaux ils ont peut-être aussi
besoin d'être protégés vous l'entendez
ça je l'entends mais il ya déjà des lois
qui lutte contre la haine sur les
réseaux sociaux il ya déjà des gens qui
ont été condamnés pour pour armer des
policiers pour avoir peur
des appels à la haine donc il ya déjà
des choses qui existent en fait donc
pourquoi refaire pour pas faire fait loi
de sécurité globale pourquoi vouloir
porter porter atteinte à la liberté de
la presse
je sais c'était une question qu'il faut
poser aujourd'hui est bien on va la
pause et pierre benoit pas beau du
châtelard qui est le juriste en marche
sur ce plateau est peut-être que sa
réponse va vous intéresser je l'espère
c'est un vrai débat quand même cette loi
elle fait même pas l'unanimité vraiment
ch est en marche vous vous la défendez
et vous êtes quand même rassuré par
l'arrivée de cette avance cet amendement
un peu surprise vendredi dernier pour
garantir la liberté d'informer alors
c'est un énorme débat c'est un débat
même abrasif je crois qu'on peut le dire
et quand vous parlez de position je
préfère mettre tout de suite les choses
au clair au clair en ce sens que chez
jurait mais évidemment on défend la
liberté de la presse principe
constitutionnel reconnu par article 10
de convention européenne des droits de
l'homme et la position que j'ai exprimés
maintenant c'est pas la position du
comité jurés même qui est pas une
commune qui a pas de position arrêtée
parce que le texte n'a pas fini son
voyage parlementaire
donc on attend bien sûr personne n'est
d'accord et il n'y a pas de consensus
sur la qualité du texte qui propose
aujourd'hui
maintenant ce qui est certain c'est que
il ya des violences contre les policiers
qui ont été soulignés dans un rapport de
politique pénale qui avait été préparé
en mai 2010 est par jean jacques urvoas
ces violences ont augmenté notamment
dans le contexte de la crise dg jaune
aujourd'hui on a des phénomènes de
cybercriminalité ou en effet il ya des
citoyens qui peut être des citoyens
normaux mais aussi des policiers qui
sont jetés en pâture sur les réseaux
sociaux
et on se regarde aujourd'hui le corpus
juridique et toutes les différentes
infractions sur lesquelles on pourrait
se fonder pour intervenir et éviter que
les policiers soient le jeter en pâture
sur les réseaux sociaux on se rend
compte qu'il ya des trous dans la
raquette
c'est aussi simple que ça et aujourd'hui
l'article 24 son seul objectif c'est de
pas enfreint des libertés de la presse
mais de combler ce trou dans la raquette
et donc par rapport à ce qu'il propose
moi je trouve que c'est une solution
cohérente je dis pas que ce qui a été
aménagé vendredi dernier donne plus de
confort parce que le fait de dire que ce
n'est pas contraire à bata de la presse
on n'avait pas forcément besoin mais je
trouve qu'on va dans le bon sens
aujourd'hui vous avez cet article qui
n'interdit à personne de films et vous
avez la liberté de la presse les gens
peuvent continuer à filmer les gens
peuvent continuer à diffuser et par
rapport à ce que j'entends et je
voudrais être clair là dessus parce que
je pense qu'on aura l'occasion d'en
débattre si le temps nous le permet
aujourd'hui les policiers ont
l'interdiction de se saisir des
téléphones portables ou de matériel qui
retransmet des images au cours d'une
intervention de police les policiers
n'ont pas de droits à l'image n'ont pas
de droit à l'image est par ailleurs ya
une circulaire de 2008 qu'elle
circulaire sarkozy qui leur interdit de
se saisir du matériel vidéo au cours de
diffusion d'image jean philippe derosier
oui présent j'imagine que vous avez un
avis sur cette loi
oui couler tant d'encre de je suis
extrêmement réservé et sceptique quant à
l'ensemble du processus quant aux
intentions du gouvernement qui en
réalité ressorte et alimentent un climat
de tension oui il y à des violences
contre les policiers on ne peut pas les
nier mais il ya aussi des violences des
policiers contre les manifestants aligné
non plus je ne pense pas que les
violences des policiers contre les
manifestants soient faits commis de la
part de la majorité des policiers de
même que je ne pense pas que la majorité
des policiers fassent l'objet de
violences ou d'appel à la violence sur
les réseaux sociaux les violences où les
appels à la violence à la haine sur les
réseaux sociaux
je pense qu'on sera tous d'accord y
compris au sein de l'ensemble des
juristes en marche pour dire que peut
pas les laisser faire il faut les
condamner et poursuivre leurs auteurs
en revanche il existe déjà des
dispositifs
peut-être sont-ils insuffisant de même
qu' il existe des îles dispositif
interdisant la propagation l'incitation
à la haine raciale ou quelque autre
forme de haine sur les réseaux sociaux
ça ne concerne pas que la police est là
il ya effectivement une réflexion à
avoir mais qui n'est pas qui ne concerne
pas que la police mme cet article 24
quel est son sa difficulté avant même de
rentrer dans le débat constitutionnel
c'est que il pointe du doigt un aspect
d'un problème qui est beaucoup plus
large et auquel il faudrait s'attaquer
de façon beaucoup plus large c'est à
dire le contrôle ou non les façon de
réguler ce qui est sûr les réseaux
sociaux nations auxquelles problèmes
auxquels la proposition loi de madame
avia s'était déjà attaqué mais dans des
façons qui précisément portait atteinte
à la liberté d'expression et là nous y
venons nous sommes encore dans une
situation où la liberté d'expression est
restreinte le la liberté de la presse le
droit d'informer
on ne peut le valablement s'exprimer
qu'à partir du moment où on est dûment
informé parce qu'il faut savoir ce sur
quoi l'on s'exprime cette liberté de la
presse est précisément pointé du doigt
parce que ce sont les journalistes
d'abord et les citoyens ensuite en tant
que lanceur d alerte qui diffuse
certaines images des forces de l'ordre
lorsque ils commettent ce que l'on
pourrait appeler des malversations qui
l'empêchent de diffuser enfin je m'étais
bien ici précisément c'est précisément
vos flux personnel avant de personnes
les personnes ne les empêche de capter
la loi ne les empêche pas de capter mais
la loi vise précisément alors interdire
de diffuser alors s'ils portent atteinte
à l'intégrité physique ou psychique et
là aussi on en revient sur le débat
relatif à la définition de l'intégrité
psychique parce que nous reste une
quarantaine de la profession parce que
la diffusion n'est pas interdite il
s'agit de la diffusion malveillantes qui
aurait pour effet deux d'identifier un
policier dans le cadre du vin dit mais
comment de juridiquement une intention
malveillante landes
ce que je veux dire c'est il ya deux cas
de figure enfin des violences policières
et j'ai joué avec bien entendu on est on
est d'accord pour lé on souhaite les
dénoncer mais aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui
filme des violences policières déjà il
peut le faire
ensuite il peut les diffuser si lui-même
il a un doute en disant est ce que je
risque d'être sanctionné il le foot
comme vous le dites et je veux dire peu
importe finalement qui a commis une
violence policière s'il a des idées des
yeux marrons des yeux verts s'il a une
barbe ou pas ce cas présent c'est qu'il
ya des violences policières qui ont été
dénoncés avec la possibilité de
transmettre les images aux autorités
administratives et judiciaires
compétentes qui elles pourront statuer
et pour nous il nous semblait cette loi
risque de créer davantage de problèmes
que d'en résoudre et l'on voit bien
qu'on le voit bien à travers le débat
que l'on que l'on a et surtout elle
entretient ce climat de tension
vis-à-vis des forces de l'ordre les
incitant à interdire précisément ce que
cette qualification s'était classée 1re
mais qu on l'organisera parce que le
texte arrivera au sénat et je vous
inviterai promis pour en reparler merci
infiniment à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce match des idées